a todos nós temos fazer um como assustar
a namorada e você já sabe o teu super
habituada a testar o pito super
habituada irritar o pe mas hoje eu vou
testar a minha namorada eu não sei como
é que está a correr vai dá vai da merda
mas ela tem susto inclusive eu dei
personagens de filmes de terror ou aí
deixa só que eu tenho aqui na nossa
amiga feira meu deus eu não sei como é
que está a correr pessoal esse pode dar
bem como pode dar errado eu não sei
fazer como com vocês pessoal para deixar
é muito aqui neste vídeo se inscreve no
canal vamos tentar chegar aos 100 mil
likes só nós chegamos aos 100 likes eu
vou fazer um como irritar um jogador de
lol assim tão rápido que você já que é
muito tempo quem ai outra coisa antes
que me esqueça pessoal para quem gosta
de jogos de terror de gameplay tem um
segundo canal é o primeiro link na
descrição ai ai
e aí
g1
[Música]
a expressão entra lá pessoal a tua
colocar um vídeo por dia ok portanto
posso ir lá e inscrevam-se bora lá o
vídeo é
e aí
bom então vamos lá com a mamãe ai ai
o que é uma coisa fazer uma coisa lá
fora ok é isso aí
e aí
o contador minhocas e
e fala olha a sério vocês assim toda
criança também meu fio então a hora de
ver o meu filme ok pessoal está a correr
bem está a correr muito bem porque ele
costuma ficar furiosa
tá frio aí
e aí
e pronto deixo isso aqui ó
e então fui apanhado a
o que é que faz para a casa de banho com
leite não fazer nada no leite eu vou
deixar aí
e eu vou lá para cima
e para essa pergunta é
e olha dormir
o irmão
e aí
oi como é que está sofá para onde é que
estás
g1
oi lala tudo limpar não então não eu é
que não vou ajudar
e aí
é um foi não para naná e
há dois mil anos depois o
e aí
e aqui abertura 1
e ela tá muito pacífica eu posso avisar
que estava aqui em casa e não acontece
isso mesmo ela fica muito muito furiosa
eu acho que é a câmera mesmo vocês
entendam é um facto ok mas agora ainda
falta pessoal ainda falta agora é
ferreira eu até hoje ainda não sei como
é que eu coloco essa marca sopa de
macaco
[Música]
e aí
e eu vou esperar que uma hora uma hora e
meia para ela se deitar para dar tempo
para ela relaxar o que ela pensar que eu
acabei de fazer o vídeo eu espero com
muita sorte eu vou ganhar eu dormir dois
mil anos depois
[Música]
g1
e aí
[Música]
o art
o ok esse foi o último esse foi o outro
é
a perinha fui assustar e
o uso do pronome pessoal esse foi o que
ela que está a namorada estou super
ansioso para ver isso na edição o que é
menos tentar incrível para tua cara tá
sempre no canal daqui da também passei
lá o link também tá na descrição e ela
faz o que fecha ali sexy makeup ou seja
é que a mamãe que pediu os transformam
em monstros em postagens filmes terror
tipo anabela pereira nos zombies bem
catarina não fizeste né enfim pessoal
passei lá visite o canal dela inscrevam
ser muito louco se gostarem inscrevam-se
vamos ficar por aqui com esse como
ajustar a namorada meu cabelo tá
horrível não sei se esqueçam de comentar
que parece um artista aqui porque eu sei
que pareço só que mais feio né mas aí
pessoal já sabem deixei sem milagres
aqui neste vídeo lá e sair o próximo é
bom que deixem muito like que eu sofri
acho que era tu estás a hora que sai o
segundo episódio ela pediu e vai
aparecer bora lá pessoal é